oui à noir El Sadate 62 ans chef de
l'État égyptien depuis 11 ans c'était
pour les occidentaux l'homme de la paix
avec Israël mais c'était aussi pour une
partie du monde arabe et pour une
opposition de plus en plus coréens en
Egypte même la bête noire le personnage
s'adapte Bernard Benyamine
Sadate lance son armée à travers le
canal de Suez les défenses israéliennes
s'effondrent les Égyptiens ont réussi
l'impossible le canal c'était pour eux
la main étrangère sur leur sol en le
reprenant ils ont retrouvé leur dignité
du coup celui que l'on prenait pour un
homme de transition après la mort de
Nasser devient un héros national mais
surtout ce prestige retrouvait cette
semi-victoire à les rendre possible la
paix
le processus commence donc le 19
novembre 1977 à Noël Sadate engageant
une formidable partie de poker arrive à
Jérusalem à ce moment-là tout est
possible y compris le pire
on lui présente moshedayan il pouvait
lui dire bonjour monsieur le ministre
mais c'est un shalomocher que les
officiels d'Israéliens entendent médusés
il rencontre goldamer et elle que l'on a
si souvent brûlé en effigie dans les
rues du Caire il lui baise la main dans
des milliers de foyers israéliens on
pleure le miracle s'est produit mais
c'est peut-être en se rendant à Yad
Vachem le mémorial au martyrs
s'adape une carte déterminante à
l'adresse du monde entier pour la
première fois un arabe fait le lien
entre l'holocauste nazi et la nécessité
de créer un État d'Israël plus que tous
les discours c'est cette visite qui va
profondément marquer les esprits en
Israël
mais ce musulman pieux qui porte au
front le zébibe la petite callosité des
bons croyants se prosternant cinq fois
par jour en direction de la Mecque
n'oublie pas pour autant son peuple
n'oublie pas pour autant la nation arabe
il se rend à la mosquée à l'AXA de
Jérusalem pour prier et quelques heures
plus tard il va se faire le défenseur
intransigeant de la cause arabe du haut
de la tribune de
par la dureté du discours mais Anouar El
Sadate va réussir à provoquer à forcer
leur admiration pour son courage il va
faire mieux quelques heures plus tard au
cours d'une scène extraordinaire qui se
déroule à l'acnée 7 avec Madame goldamel
c'est un face à face étonnant entre la
grand-mère d'Israël et celui qui vient
d'avoir une petite fille 24 heures
auparavant
je veux la paix de vie madame goldamère
et même une vieille femme comme moi oui
oui monsieur le Président vous m'avez
souvent traité de vieilles femmes même
une vieille femme comme moi veut la paix
je veux que nous vivions en paix vous et
nous
ça ne se passe alors permettez-moi
monsieur le Président permettait à une
grand-mère de faire un cadeau à un
grand-père c'est pour votre petite fille
mais les ennuis vont commencer dès le
retour au Caire danoir El Sadate même si
ce jour-là ils sont des milliers dans
les rues à acclamer le raïs cette visite
à Jérusalem n'a pas fait que des heureux
loin de là toute une frange de la classe
politique égyptienne crainte que se
rapprochement avec Israël ne se fasse
sur le dos de la nation arabes en
général et des Palestiniens en
particulier les longues tractations
entre les deux pays qui aboutiront
finalement aux accords de Cam David vont
les conforter dans leur crainte c'est
une paix séparée distille le reste du
monde arabe n'est pas concerné les
Palestiniens sont oubliés sa date nous a
trahi voilà sans doute et en l'absence
de plus amples éléments d'information
sur l'attentat d'aujourd'hui voilà sans
doute l'un des sentiments clés qui ont
pu pousser une partie de l'armée
égyptienne
ah bah Anouar El Saddad cette paix avec
Israël n'était pas la leur dénoncée par
l'ensemble des pays arabes de la région
elle n'avait fait qu'accroître
l'isolement de l'Egypte la preuve
distille l'autonomie palestinienne sur
laquelle but depuis 3 ans toutes les
négociations entre les deux pays est une
utopie Israël n'en veut pas
la deuxième cause probable à cette
assassinat c'est la montée de
l'intégrisme religieux en Égypte et la
répression sans précédent qui sont
suivies il y a tout juste un mois plus
de 1500 personnes et étaient arrêtées au
Caire des religieux surtout mais aussi
tous les opposants qui critiquaient à
noir et sa date c'est sans doute le
dernier geste politique du président
égyptien celui qui aura le plus irrité
son armée au point de lui coûter la vie
en ce 6 octobre jour anniversaire de la
guerre du Kippour cette guerre décidait
paranoha el-Sadate pour redonner
confiance à l'armée égyptienne